Deadpool 2 was bigger, louder, and packed
with even more insanity than the original
Deadpool.
Still, for as bombastic as the movie was,
there were a surprising number of subtle references
and obscure characters adapted for the big
screen.
From a lesson on box office history to quick
nods to comic book continuity, here are small
details you missed in Deadpool 2.
"And I hope you're watching!"
R-rated domination
In Deadpool 2, the Merc with a Mouth acknowledges
the success of Deadpool by telling the audience
about the box office history of some of the
highest-grossing R-rated movies.
That lesson wouldn't be complete without mentioning
the highest-grossing R-rated movie in U.S.
box office history: The Passion of the Christ.
The film earned an astonishing domestic gross
of over $370 million.
While Mel Gibson's biblical epic might never
get toppled from its throne in terms of how
much it made in America, it's a different
story internationally.
Deadpool managed to earn a staggering $783
million worldwide, making the violent superhero
romp the highest-grossing R-rated international
film of all time.
Not bad for a character that once got beat
up by Squirrel Girl.
Pryor's Treats
X-Men continuity is generally a confusing
mess spread through dozens of comic series,
as well as decades of retcons and unusual,
complicated familial revelations.
Even within that knot of continuity, there's
arguably no character with a more complicated
family history than Cable.
As the son of Scott Summers and a clone of
Jean Grey named Madelyne Pryor, Nathaniel
Summers has been to the future, was infected
with a techno-organic virus by a powerful
supervillain, and even fled through time protecting
a little girl that looks suspiciously like
his own mother.
In short, he's pretty complicated.
While Deadpool 2 stays away from too many
blatant Easter Eggs involving Josh Brolin's
Cable, there are quick references to his comic
book roots.
Immediately after most of the newly-formed
X-Force parachutes into a suburban neighborhood
and meet their untimely demises, an ice cream
truck can be seen with a logo reading "Pryor's
Treats," referring to Cable's biological mother,
Madelyne Pryor.
House of M
Deadpool's no stranger to twisted timelines
himself, as his dialogue in both Deadpool
and Deadpool 2 would suggest.
"Let us go talk to the professor."
"McAvoy or Stewart?
These timelines are so confusing."
From metatextual knowledge of Professor Xavier's
different actors to his blasé relationship
with time-travel, the Merc with a Mouth seems
to take it all in stride.
Still, maybe he should have been a little
more worried about the banners that hung inside
the Essex House that read "M-Day is Coming."
Long-time comic readers might remember that
M-Day is the in-universe term for when Scarlet
Witch erases the mutant genome in House of
M. M-Day goes down in Marvel history as a
dark time for mutants, since the resulting
wipe of the mutant race sticks around for
years.
The mutant population in the Marvel universe
actually drops from tens of thousands all
the way to just a couple hundred.
For years, the mutant population slowly dwindles,
right until a very important mutant baby is
born.
That mutant?
Hope Summers, Cable's daughter.
No wonder Cable's so grumpy in the movie if
he's from such a grim future.
Irene Merryweather
During Russell Collins' first fiery appearance
in Deadpool 2, even the on-scene reporter
is a supporting character who appeared in
the comic series Cable & Deadpool.
Like her movie counterpart, Irene Merryweather
is a reporter, but the comics version of the
character goes on a much wilder series of
adventures than her quick movie appearance
would suggest.
She's been the chronicler of Cable's adventures,
a writer for the Daily Bugle, an object of
Deadpool's romantic affections, and the Chief
of Staff of an entire island-state.
That's a heck of a resume.
X-Men fan
While movie Deadpool can pretend to be too
cool for Xavier's school, comic book Deadpool
is a pretty big X-Men fan.
Since Deadpool breaks the fourth wall more
often than the Wrecking Crew breaks actual
walls, this manifests in him referencing specific
issue numbers when he gets excited in Deadpool
2.
When Juggernaut appears, the Merc with a Mouth
tells him how big a fan he is and names three
Juggernaut-centric comic book issues: Uncanny
X-Men #183, X-Men Unlimited #12, and Thor
#411.
Beyond just featuring the Juggernaut, all
three issues have a thematic connection, as
well; Juggernaut taking down increasingly
powerful enemies.
In Uncanny X-Men #183, Juggernaut brings an
entire building down on Colossus in a bar
fight.
In Thor #411, Juggernaut fights and completely
defeats Thor, the God of Thunder.
Finally, in X-Men Unlimited #12, Juggernaut
fights the cosmic entity that controls his
power, Cytorrak, and defeats him too.
If Deadpool's been reading these comics, it's
no wonder he's such a fan of Cain Marko.
And when Deadpool says, quote, "It has always
been a dream of mine to see myself reflected
in your helmet as you charge at me with murderous
intent"?
Well that actually happened on the cover of
his own book, on Deadpool #2.
Dreams really do come true.
Beyond the comic book reference, there's a
very good reason for Deadpool to get excited
about fighting the Juggernaut.
Much like having a tragic origin or joining
the Avengers, fighting the unstoppable force
of the Juggernaut is basically a rite of passage
in the Marvel universe.
Colossus did it, Thor did it, even Spider-Man
has done it.
Welcome to the big leagues, Wade Wilson.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!